au coeur de l'amazonie brésilienne le
coronavirus s'est installé au total près
de 8000 cas de kovy 19 ont été recensés
chez les populations indigènes et près
de 184 décès rapportés une situation
inquiétante étant donné le peu de
ressources dont dispose cette population
en raison de la pandémie
les peuples indigènes n'ont en effet pas
pu se rendre dans les villes pour vendre
leurs produits ou acheter des vivres
parmi les ethnies qui peuplent amazonie
les riverains de loi touma un affluent
de l'amazone une communauté vivant de
l'agriculture durable et du
développement des terres forestières une
population qui se trouve aujourd'hui en
grand besoin
la population dépend beaucoup de l'aide
et des donations car nous ne pouvons pas
partir nous avons été prévenus qu'il ne
fallait pas partir
ne pas aller en ville à cause du risque
de contamination restait isolé pour
empêcher la propagation du copic 19 les
ouates oumma bénéficie tout de même
aujourd'hui d'une aide extérieure
une aide nécessaire cette aide nous
aident à éviter le contact direct avec
les lieux où il ya le plus de cas et
cela aide aussi à ne pas répandre le
colis de 19 dans notre communauté
au total 500 kits contenant des produits
essentiels notamment de la nourriture
des produits de nettoyage et des masques
ont été distribués à plus de 400
familles de 20 communautés aux passants
sega a eu notre but est d'atteindre les
endroits où les autorités publiques aux
six emplois théâtre il avait très peu de
ressources
dans le passé nous nous concentrions
déjà sur les groupes vulnérables pas
seulement de promenade avec le
coronavirus une action réalisé en
coordination entre les membres de
l'amazone sustainable foundation
d'autres ong des universités et le
gouvernement de l'état d'amazonas une
charité bien loin d'être prônée par le
président brésilien raï airball sonar au
pourtant contaminée par le colis de 19 a
opposé cette semaine son veto partiel un
projet de loi destiné à protéger les
peuples indigènes parmi ces articles de
loi certains prévoient
obligation faite au gouvernement de
fournir les autochtones en eau potable
ou encore de leur prodiguer les soins
d'urgence 16 articles ont été supprimées
par le président brésilien
une décision criminelle pour l'iss à une
ong brésilienne
de son côté la cour suprême exige que le
gouvernement présente un plan de
protection des communautés indigènes
pour rappel le brésil avec sa population
de 210 millions d'habitants est le
deuxième pays le plus touché au monde
par le cos vite 19